your tattoos are inside your immune
system literally with each very tasteful
piece of art you Kickstart a drama with
millions of deaths Grand sacrifices and
your immune system stepping in to
protect you from yourself let's give you
a tattoo and zoom in to see what happens
inside your
skin the conveyor belt of death your
skin has to solve a huge problem it's
your largest organ and has the most
direct contact with the world around you
trillions of microbes dirt insects and
Vermin can't be allowed to get inside
you but your skin is also constantly
damaged by you moving through the world
your body solved this by making your
skin a convey belt of death all the skin
you see is actually dead stuff the alive
part of your skin cells begins around 1
mm deep in the skin industrial complex
stem cells constantly clone cells
producing new skin cells that begin a
journey from the inside to the outside
each new generation pushes the older
ones further up as your skin cells
mature they interlock with each other
and produce Lamar bodies tiny bags that
squirt out fat to create a waterproof
coat that closes any gaps between them
and then they dry out and kill
themselves merging together into
Inseparable lumps this wall of dead
corpses is consistently pushed upwards
up to 50 layers of dead cells cover your
whole body and are constantly replaced
by new cells moving up every hour you
shed around 200 million dead skin cells
and all the dirt or bacteria that are
stuck to them tattooing this part of
your skin would be useless as nothing
would stick around we need to go deeper
when the fleshy World explodes below the
conveyor belt of death lies the dermis
it's full of structural tissue and cells
tiny blood vessels sensory cells that
report to nerve endings the roots of
your hairs sweat glands regulating your
temperature and of course loads of
immune cells guarding your flesh right
below the moving border wall this region
and below is where your new tattoo will
go okay ready the world explodes half a
dozen monoliths the size of skyscrapers
slam through the 50 layers of dead cells
deep into the dermis ripping huge holes
into the skin only to retreat and smash
through the tissue again about twice a
second tens of thousands of cells are
violently killed right away ripped into
pieces or damaged Beyond repair luckily
you did your research and chose a
responsible to two artist who properly
disinfected their tools and your skin
but you only ever get 99.9% of all
bacteria and some of the survivors made
it into your flesh to put it mly your
immune system is not amused at all all
the death and destruction wakes up
hundreds of thousands of of macrofagos
in your dermis that rush into the open
wounds to defend you immediately they
start killing bacteria release chemicals
that cool for reinforcements and order
your blood vessels to open up and make
your dermis swell up with fluid but
worse than the hundreds of wounds and a
few Invaders is the tidal wave of
chemicals that floods your tissue tattoo
ink could be made from hundreds of
substances some may even be toxic or
cogenic most are from heavy metals like
lead nickel or chromium dissolved in
distilled water the battlefield is now a
wild mix of dead cell parts a few
panicked bacteria blood and bodily
fluids platelet cells trying to close
wounds more and more fresh immune cells
and the flood of tat ink on the scale of
your cells clumps of ink particles are
huge if you were the size of a cell
they'd range from big dogs to small
Office Buildings your immune system has
one main job identify what is not you
and smash it until it's dead the macro
fases are desperately trying to do that
like tiny octopuses they extend armik
structures and begin pulling the ink
particles inside usually when a maccrage
has eaten an enemy it showers it in acid
to dissolve it but this doesn't work
with the ink they try and try but
nothing works the particles don't react
in any way and this is just the particle
small enough to be devoured by now the
larger chunks are surrounded by
thousands of your structural skin cells
and acreages that are noming on them
bathing them in acid and attack
chemicals trying to destroy and kill
them but they're not moving even a tiny
bit nothing works finally your immune
system has to conceit it will not win
this fight so it does the next best
thing not lose your cells don't know how
dangerous these metals and chemicals are
but they can at least not let them
spread around so they just stay in place
they vacuum up all the particles they
can fit into their bodies and surround
the larger ones trapping them in the
only prison they can build themselves
bit by bit the ink inside thousands of
tiny wounds moves inside millions of
immune cells that freeze in place
Forever on the outside you don't notice
any of this your new tat is fresh and
the color is vibrant your skin hurts and
is irritated and swollen but wounds heal
tiny holes close dead cells are replaced
bit by bit the conveyor belt of death
does its job shedding dead cells rip in
color replacing them with fresh and
clean ones your tattoo becomes a little
less vibrant now the ink is no longer on
your skin but inside it but what you're
really seeing is millions of your
macrofagos sitting in your dermis
patiently holding the ink in place
protecting your body from Poison your
immune system is why your tattoo is
forever actually nothing is forever over
time your macras get old and die and new
ones come in to gobble up the ink and
keep it in place but sometimes times a
tiny bit of ink escapes most of it is
recaptured and locked in place but not
always the exact same place you notice
that as your tattoo Fades out a bit and
turns less sharp and crisp at its edges
some of the ink escapes the tattoo
entirely it rides fluids flowing from
your tissue and spreads around your body
another reason why tou ink should
ideally not be poison your immune system
also kind of doesn't want you to remove
tattoos to do that usually the is shot
at with lasers which heats up the
particles until they break into smaller
chunks cooking Your brave macras in the
process with every round of lasering
more of your tattoo is broken down and
carried away by fluids but also every
time new macrofagos rush into the tattoo
to lock the ink in place so like H maybe
think about it carefully before you get
the name of your new bay tude but you do
you but if you got one you can directly
see your immune system protecting you
this is how how much your body loves you
which is kind of sweet and while tattoos
are probably not that big of a deal for
your body if applied correctly you now
know about the struggle going on inside
your skin and the sacrifice of your
maccrage buddies only for you to have
that art
forever to appreciate your amazing
immune system you have to know about it
first and the same goes for anything
going on in our universe to help you
with that we've created a series of
lessons to take your scientific
knowledge to the next level made in
collaboration with our friends at
brilliant.org these lessons let you
further explore the topics in our most
popular videos from rabis and mamalian
Metabolism to climate science and supern
noi brilliant has thousands of lessons
to explore and each one is interactive
like a one-on-one version of a quazar
video brilliant's latest course how
nlm's work takes you under the hood of
real language models it demystifies
Technologies like chat GPT with
interactive lessons on everything from
how models build vocabulary to how they
choose their next word you'll learn how
to tune llms to produce output with
exactly your desired tonality whether
it's poetry or a cover letter and you'll
understand why training is really
everything by comparing models trained
on Taylor Swift lyrics and the legal
speech of big Tech terms and conditions
this isn't just another course it's an
immersive AI Workshop allowing you to
experience and harness the mechanics of
today's most advanced tool to get hands
on with courts gazar lessons and explore
everything brilliant has to offer you
can start your free 30-day trial by
signing up at brilliant.org nutshell
there's even an extra perk for kazak
viewers the first 200 people to use the
link get 20% of an annual membership
once their trial ends we love seeing how
the gears interlock with our research
brilliant gives you the tools to
understand how everything fits
[Music]
together